this is curt nevina reading for richard
wakeling teenage mutant ninja turtles
shredders revenge is fueled by the power
of nostalgia and presumably dozens upon
dozens of slices of new york pizza
1992's turtles and thyme is one of the
most beloved super nintendo games
arriving at a time when the heroes in a
half shell were at the peak of their
popularity it's clear that the
beat-em-up connoisseurs at developer
tribute games have a deep reverence for
both that game and the turtles of the
late 80s and early 90s because
shredder's revenge is essentially a
sequel 30 years in the making it
faithfully recaptures what made turtles
and times such a cherished brawler all
while introducing a few new ideas to
freshen up the classic 16-bit gameplay
for a modern audience
[Music]
if you're a fan of turtles and time
you'll feel right at home as soon as
shredder's revenge begins the opening
cut scene sees the anthropomorphic
brothers gathered around an old crt tv
watching a news report that's
interrupted when a few of their
notorious adversaries attacked the
statue of liberty it's not exactly the
same as turtle and times opening but
it's very close once you hop into the
first level this feeling of familiarity
doesn't wear off the level introductions
feature the same silhouette of the boss
you'll be facing and if you're playing
as either leonardo donatello raphael or
michelangelo you'll notice that their
abilities and combos have been
faithfully adapted from their adventure
in 92 chaining together attacks is more
fluid than it once was but you can still
perform a plethora of recognizable moves
from barreling enemies over with a
running shoulder charge to cancelling a
dodge in order to launch into a slide
kick you could even grab foot soldiers
and toss them right at the camera
playing shredder's revenge feels like
playing turtles in time or at least how
i remember it in my mind's eye but
they're still fun to be had even if you
don't possess any of that potent
nostalgia it's still very much inspired
by the beat-em-ups of the era including
the earlier turtles games released for
the nes with its fast arcade style
action seeing enemies arrive on screen
just as quickly as they're vanquished
there's a ton of enemy variety too which
often forces you to diversify your
offense to get behind a shielded foe or
dispatch a flying nuisance defeating
most of the bosses is a matter of
learning their attack patterns and
knowing when to dodge and when to
inflict damage a few of these end of the
level obstacles are more involved though
such as the rat king who will jump out
of harm's way and summon swarms of rats
for you to evade it's all relatively
simple but there's some depth beyond the
surface with the likes of juggles and
ground bounces and the swift rhythm of
the action is particularly satisfying
by turtles
no
shredders revenge also introduces a
number of new features and a few quality
of life improvements as well each
character has a unique super attack that
lets them deal a ton of damage for a
couple of seconds rather than having to
sacrifice health to utilize these
attacks you now have a charge meter that
fills up as you do damage if there is a
respite in the action you can also taunt
to fill up the meter which sees
donatello pull out and play game boy
while michelangelo dances on the spot
just a minute
[Music]
these add moments of characters aside
from the obvious gameplay benefits you
also have a charged heavy attack that's
useful against shielded enemies and
quick foes that have a habit of dashing
across the screen if you're playing
co-op which supports up to six players
either online or locally you can
high-five each other to share health
and you'll also enter a down state if
your health bar is depleted giving your
teammates a brief window in which to
revive you with the rejuvenating power
of pizza co-op represents shredders
revenge at its most chaotic i played
with three friends and that was manic
enough so a six player game must be
absolute carnage this is mainly because
the game adapts depending on how many
players there are by throwing more foot
soldiers into the mix keeping track of
where your character is might be the
hardest part considering how much is
happening on screen at any given time
and there were multiple occasions where
i found myself attacking nothing at the
side of the screen because i thought i
was somewhere else playing as either
april o'neil splinter or the unlockable
casey jones makes this slightly easier
since you don't blend in with the
turtles quite as much embracing the
chaos is the best way to go though and
ultimately it doesn't significantly
deter from how much fun it is to play
with friends the only time this isn't
the case is during a couple of levels
where you're riding a turtle's
hoverboard since you're constantly
moving forward dodging obstacles proves
overly difficult when you can't tell
what's going on making these levels
fairly frustrating this isn't an issue
when playing solo just during co-op when
the screen can get exceedingly busy most
of the levels are fantastic however
being both varied and full of amusing
details the first level for instance
sees you chasing bebop through the
channel 6 new studio one of the running
gags in shredder's revenge is centered
on how bad the foot clan is at blending
into the environment as you move through
the tv studio you'll see them typing
away on computers turning a cake mixture
on the kitchen set and emerging from an
industrial freezer with frozen hams that
are now handy projectile weapons
meanwhile another level sees you fight
your way through a mall where foot
soldiers are walking through the food
court with burgers and fries playing
games in the arcade it nails the tone
and fun-loving personality of the late
80s and early 90s turtles the colorful
16-bit aesthetic is also a treat and the
excellent music sounds like it was
ripped straight from that era
[Music]
you can easily finish shredder's revenge
and around two and a half hours which is
definitely on the short side but there
is a decent amount of replayability the
game has two different modes story and
arcade the former features an overworld
and an incentive to replay levels in
order to complete challenges find hidden
npcs and finish fetch quests which boils
down to hitting every obstacle inside a
level to unearth these hidden secrets
on the floor this isn't engaging in any
way but doing so will reward you with
points that feed into a light
progression system that increases your
health bar unlocks new moves like diving
special attacks and more arcade on the
other hand dilutes the experience down
to the fundamentals you can't save and
only have a limited number of lives so
you need to complete the whole game in a
single run without dying too much
you know like the good old days playing
through the game multiple times also
gives you a chance to try out all the
playable characters each of the six has
a trio of stats range speed and power
that makes them feel distinct whether
you're able to extract more playtime out
of shredder's revenge or not will depend
on how willing you are to replay levels
with other characters and on higher
difficulty levels despite its brevity
however this is a tremendous labor of
love that lives up to the legacy of
turtles and time and the brawlers that
came before it combat is fast-paced and
simple yet satisfying while new features
help modernize the action without
tampering with its 16-bit essence co-op
is overly chaotic and can use some
indicators to help you keep track of
where you are but playing with friends
is still a blast rehashing a classic
retro game is always a tough ask but
shredder's revenge avoids the obvious
pitfalls and successfully brings about a
revival of everyone's favorite mutant
turtles
hmm
[Music]
way to go
[Music]